Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn his time for the Monday
morning podcast for Monday, January 19th.
No, January 9th, sorry, 2017.
January 9th, 2017. You know,
that's how bad I am at math.
I can't even fucking say that date.
Right. Um, how's has a goal and how?
Oh,
the summer wind,
it came fucking blowing in
because of global warming.
It's fucking cold for about
two weeks and then it's hot.
My fucking house is gonna Melt and
then it will slip into the sea.
I don't give a fuck that it's
snowing and Massachusetts.
[inaudible] Hey, what's
going? What's going on?
It's already getting hot
as fuck out here. Uh, dude,
you should be a meteorologist.
Yeah, it's going to be,
he's fucking fucking Los
Angeles. Um, how are you?
How's it going? Are you out there?
You're fighting the good fight.
You're trying to be a better person.
You're trying to turn around your
fucking childhood. Well, join the club.
Had a little setback yesterday,
you know?
Oh fuck a knew Billy was running around
an old William showed up less today.
Just I, you know, whatever. I just got to
keep fucking, you know, moving forward,
you know, moving forward like
the Celtics and the Bruins. Okay.
When I went and championships this year,
but you know, we're trying, all right,
I'm not going to get rid of all
of my anger in fucking two weeks,
but you know, if you can just
chop away even a half a percent,
you'll be a half a percent better
today than you were yesterday.
Jesus Christ,
you know,
you know what's fucked up is knowing that
you fucked up and then actually really
analyzing yourself and you're like,
Whoa, I didn't know it was that deep.
Um, anyways, so what do you do?
What do you do when you know you're
fucked up and you can't really fix it?
Then Day, what do you do? Well, you know,
what you do is you fucking crack open a
beer and you watch some God damn sports.
That's what you do to distract yourself
from all this shit that's going on.
I love this whole fucking story about
the Russians hacking into the fucking
democratic national fucking convention
committee, fucking websites and all that.
All these fucking Hillary supporters.
Yay.
It's why are you fucking Trump was
able to eke it out. It's just like,
I can't even fucking,
I can't listen to any. And then you
look at the Trump supporters are like,
what's the big deal?
It's just the Russian.
The bottom line is you either give a
fuck or don't give a fuck about what the
Russians allegedly did
or didn't fucking do,
depending on whether you wear a
blue tie or a fucking red tie.
And I love how in the end of all this,
like I was supposed to listen
to the fucking CIA. Like
they don't have an agenda.
Everybody in this story has a fucking
agenda. So it's like, all right,
who the fuck do I listen to?
You know,
good fucking Lord.
You think Obama would give a shit if
the hacking led to Hillary winning?
We'll uh, we'll do something a when the
time is right and we'll blah, blah, blah.
Why?
Cause The lady with the Blue Bra lost.
What if she weren't Obama? When
then, what the fuck would you do?
Give right off into the sunset.
Get ready to do your fucking speeches
for fucking 300 grand a clip to the exact
people that get you in the
White House. It's all, I
can't, that's why watch sports.
That's why I watch sports because other
than a couple of mobbed up refs here or
there, you know, it's pretty fair.
It's about as fair as it can get,
which means it isn't fair.
So anyways,
um,
I love that people don't like the Trump
is friends with Vladimir Putin obviously
since is Putnam Putnam.
You know that Ted not being friends with
the Russians the first time it didn't
work out too well with the whole thing
almost blew up in her face. So, uh,
you know,
why don't we try to hold hands this time?
I Dunno. I I, this is, I
don't get into port to eight.
I think war should be illegal.
I think war is literally,
it's the temper tantrum of the fucking
Illuminati and then everybody else has to
pay the fucking price.
You know,
and those rich loafer wearing counts will
never step one foot into a battlefield.
Uh, you know that they all
make the fucking money off.
It's just a bunch of fucking bullshit.
And when are they going to grow up?
I love how I can't go all over my
fence and just take a bad out in,
beat the fuck out of my neighbor because
of, I dunno, whatever the fuck they did.
You know,
the apple trees on their property and I
want the apples on my fucking property
and I can't just fucking try to force
them to fucking give me their apples and
when they don't,
I can then just fucking come up with an
eye down and I was some sort of angle,
a bullshit that I tell the rest of my
neighbors and I go over there and I
fucking smash up his house and kill a
few people in it. I don't, why can't,
I can't do that on a fucking local level.
But as a country,
countries can do that to one another.
It's just fucking beyond me.
The kids sit down at a
fucking table and hash it out.
Give us the oil.
No,
just sit there at the
table for fucking years.
Just doing different
reads. Give us the oil. No.
Um,
all right.
There's my fucking wing nut
fucking conspiracy theory
horseshit for you're right
out of the gate. So let's go right
back to bread and circus. Okay.
Bread and fucking circus.
You guys watch any of the play off
play off fucking football games.
I'll tell you right now,
the two luckiest teams in the NFL right
now with the Seattle Seahawks and the
New England patriots.
Why you say,
because the other two best remaining teams
in both conferences are going to play
each other next weekend.
You know,
while the Patriots played the Houston
Texans and the Seattle Seahawks play the
Atlanta Falcons. Now I'm not trying to
disrespect the Texans or the falcons,
but who's kidding who, if you see
Atul and you've got the cowboys,
the packers and the Falcons left,
which is the best game for you,
which gives you the best chance at
moving onto the next round. Wow.
Those fucking dirty birds
down there in Atlanta, uh,
with the real housewives and
the download brothers. Um,
and if in the AFC I would much rather
as a Patriot fan watches play the Texans
without JJ what?
Right.
Okay.
Playing a home game while the Kansas
City chiefs and the Pittsburgh Steelers
beat the shit out of each other.
You know,
cowboys and Green Bay are going
to eliminate one of them, right?
You know the deal.
So rather than Seattle having to go
through fucking Greenbay and Dallas,
the only got to go through one of them
and the Patriots rather than having to
play the Steelers and the fucking chiefs,
we only got to play wonderful thank
Christ the way that worked out.
So both of us,
if we play the game that we should be,
fuck that we know how to play
should easily, not easily,
but we should make it to the, uh, to the
fucking and IFC AFC championship game.
And the fucking patriots had a buy.
So we're fucking,
we're wearing flip flops to the AFC
championship game. Having said that,
I have no idea who's going
to win the super bowl.
I like many people I think were amazed
at how easily the packers handled the,
uh, the New York football
giants in As a patriots fan.
I did not enjoy that outcome
because I wanted the rematch,
you know, I said dead fucking for
the last five weeks. I want to see,
I want to fight, I wanted the
patriots play the giants again.
I wanted to see if it definitively,
if the giants just fucking own us.
Yeah.
You know, for the trilogy or
could we get some revenge?
You know what I mean? That, that's
what I was looking forward to. Um,
okay.
So, you know, when I also love Eli
and I actually loved the giants,
believe it or not,
as a patriots team,
I don't understand like as much
as those two losses were painful,
what is there to hate?
They were a great fucking franchise.
They always have a great fucking defense
and a couple of tough years. But, um,
I wanted the rematch. Oh my God, that
would have been huge fucking ratings.
Although rematch patriots, a Seattle
could also be a good thing. However,
how many times have we beaten the
Steelers in the playoffs? Playoffs.
We've beaten them up. I don't know
every fucking significant. God Damn,
I don't even know. I've lost count
this. Would this be number four?
MMM.
So you can't tell me this Steelers aren't
do and I don't know shit about Kansas
City other than people telling
me that they're really good.
So it's not going to be an
easy AFC championship game.
And if you're asking me if I'm
looking past the Dallas Texans, uh,
I kind of am, but only as a fan. I
don't play for the New England patriots.
So I think the Patriots will be fine
that I'm kind of looking past that.
The Houston Texans going into
New England without Jj. How
um, how about that fucking
catch by Richardson?
You probably should say which one,
but that one in the fucking end zone.
That was like one of the best catches I've
seen since. So Dell backups, you know,
it wasn't anywhere near as good as that.
But Jesus Christ,
fucking lily reaching around
below the guy, you know,
around his junk past Tate,
they throw a flag for an interception
is still fucking catch it.
How many fucking times is
there a flag in the end zone?
And the offensive team gets to deny it
because the fucking wide receiver reached
around, you know, that sounds fucking
perverted. But around the defender,
you know why?
Cause I stopped at reach around Rachel
around Jack reacher route fucking reached
around the defender. They probably
teach you that in broadcasting school.
You know,
and one of the main things you have to
look out for other than staying away from
advocacy of domestic violence against
women is when you're going to use the
expression that the, the,
the, the wide receiver,
how reached around the defender.
You got to get,
you can't pause after a rant.
You got to go ride to defendant reached
around the defender and then continue
with your idea. Um, anyways, sorry. So,
um,
I don't know.
A lot of people thought some of
those playoff games are boring.
I know I did the Steelers dolphins Forney
and that was a fucking snooze fest.
But it's, it's the early rounds, zero
early rounds. Everybody's evenly matched.
I think next week's will be, uh,
we've agreed. We'll be great.
We'll see what the fuck happens.
Who Do you like? Who Do you like?
I think a lot of people are on Seattle's
fucking a beak as they say, right?
Everybody's fucking looking
at them like, oh, you know,
they were just there and are, they played
pretty good against the fucking lights,
you know, and then Green Bay, Green Bay's
been there and everybody's like, ah,
you know,
fucking all of a sudden here we go.
Erin fucking Rogers look like a
beast in the second half. Right?
And then there's other people go,
oh, what about those fucking cowboy?
That's
why I don't fucking watch pre or post
game analysis. And probably why you got,
well actually,
maybe you shouldn't fast forward through
this because I'll honestly tell you,
I don't know what the fuck is
going to happen. I have no idea.
I don't know what happens.
I haven't watched Kansas City all year.
I just know that, uh, uh,
the, uh, what the fucks is,
Andy Reid is their coach in the last
time I watched them was the first time I
saw him in a red jacket and he looked
like a big fucking tomato. And I said,
you know what,
I'm done with this franchise.
And the only other time I paid attention
to was when Paul Versey kept telling me
that US trading Matt Castle or letting
them go to the chiefs who was a huge
fucking mistake.
And do you think he ever apologize
for me to me for making that sort of a
comment? I don't think he did.
Ah, I don't think he did. Um,
anyways, so I'm continuing
to try to do the impossible,
which is watch every home game of the
Boston Celtics and the Boston Bruins while
sustaining a healthy marriage.
It's not easy.
You know what makes it really fucking
hard is this Bruins and Celtics a lot of
times play on the same day.
And I for some reason never think,
but why don't you just watch one of them
and then watch the other one on the off
day? That's what I have to do. But I
watched, um, you know, I watched the,
uh,
the Celta I guess I take the Pelican game.
So I watched the Celtics beat the Pelicans
and then I watched the Bruins fucking
play the Goddamn Hartford
whalers via North Carolina. And,
uh, every time we play the fucking
hurricanes, it always goes into the lab.
We played them three times in the last
month and always goes into overtime and
we usually, we usually lose to those
cuts. I don't know what it was.
We used to own the Hartford whalers,
but every,
once they become the fucking Carolina
hurricanes, we always lose to them.
They're reminded me of what used to
happen when the Patriots would go into
Denver. We always lost, you know,
granted they had Craig Morton
and then into John Elway.
What do we have? We had Tony,
he said we had Steve Grogan's,
we couldn't match up the
orange crush defense.
And then John Elway was better than,
I'm sorry we gave you,
is better than Tony Easton and uh,
but he wasn't still on the draft board.
And I know you think we should have
picked and marina. Well, you know,
we didn't like everybody else.
We fucking did it.
And you know who paid the price
more than anybody else. Dan Marino.
Cause he went to fucking Miami and
they never got him a running game or a
defense.
And to this day people fucking trash them
saying he couldn't win the fucking big
one.
And meanwhile they had to change every
possible fucking rule in passing and tip.
It's so totally forward to the fucking,
the scales to the Office for Dan Marino's
records to finally start falling.
Yeah, I'm a big Dan Marino fan.
Anyways, plowing ahead here. Um,
and I've been watching the,
uh,
the Celtics just having a great
fucking time watching both of them,
the broads know the hanging in there.
We were out of the playoffs for
a game play offs and then we won.
I don't even know who the
fuck we beat the watches.
So we fuck agaves we'd be buffalo twice
and then we fucking lost to Edmonton and
then we'd beat somebody and then we
fucking lost in overtime tow. Uh,
still the fucking hurricanes.
I believe, I don't know it.
It gets crazy to try to
watch 162 fucking games.
MMM Benny
ways.
They're both fucking that we play the
blues and then the fucking Celtics got a
huge game against the Toronto Raptors.
Now,
if you're not watching the Celtics of
Boston, this is all you need to know.
I'm going to read you their wins and
losses and you tell me if you can fucking
pick up what's going on. We'll go back
to them beating. They beat the, uh,
all right, here we go. December 16th,
we beat the sh we beat the fucking,
yeah.
Does that say the Hornets?
One of the Hornets stopping the bobcat's.
The horn moved to New Orleans,
then they became the Pelicans and then
that name freed up and then the bobcat's
like, all right, it's really, you know,
not enough bobcat's out here in North
Carolina. Can we go back to Hornets?
Cause their mother fuckers are everywhere.
My overalls and shoo fly North Carolina.
All right.
Then we beat the Miami Heat.
Then we beat the Memphis Grizzlies,
then we beat the fucking Indiana Pacers.
Then we played the Oklahoma
City thunder and we lost that.
We played the Knicks.
We beat him.
Yeah.
Then we played the grizzlies.
We beat him.
Then we played the Cavaliers and we
lost you seeing a pattern here that we'd
beat the heat. Then we beat the
jazz, then we'd beat the sixers.
Then we beat the fucking Pelicans.
And then Tuesday we're playing the Toronto
Raptors. So if you look, we fucking,
we beat all the fucking regular Joe teams.
Lunch pail Larry's,
but we can't beat the cavs were not be
fucking Okc and now we got fucking uh,
yeah,
we got Toronto. So I dunno. I'll
be very excited if we fucking, um,
I'd be very excited if we fucker when
they came cause we haven't really been a
contender yet since I've
started watching them. Um,
okay.
But anyways, they've seen the Celtics
are like one fucking player away.
Then that one player way,
if you really watch the Cavaliers and
you watch the golden state warriors were
at least two fucking players away,
the fact that they want to move like
fucking Marcus smarter fucking Jae Crowder
for that white kid who used to play
at Butler for Brad Stevens. You know,
I'll tell you right now,
I'm reverse racist when it
comes to fucking basketball
to w we're going to trade
a black guy and draft picks for
a light guy who plays in Utah.
I Dunno for as he's telling
me the guise of beast,
whatever the Hawthorne or some shit like
that. I don't, I don't know about hoop.
I just started watching.
I'm like a fucking housewife that
finally got her Celtic Apron in.
His stop making ham hocks is
peeking into the living room,
so I don't have no idea what I'm talking
about. All I can tell you is that, uh,
I'm loving watching the
games during the Pelicans.
Got a great fucking announced it too.
I was so pissed because I love listening
to Tommy Heinsohn and the other fucking
guy. I don't know. It was
God damn name. I should,
he's been doing the Celtics games
forever, but a, the pelting dealt with,
see that that was the Pelicans and the
Celtics, the Pelicans or the pelvics.
Umm,
they actually combined her in World
War II and they played the struggles.
Um,
they get a great announcer,
old school fucking uh,
I don't know,
had a lot of elements of a Vin Scully.
I thought he was a class act.
He could tell he was rooting for
the Pelicans, but he gave, you know,
when his team committed files, he said,
all right, that's a file. You know,
he wasn't a total homer.
I like guys like that.
And I also like total Homer's like
Tommy Heinsohn. Um, all right,
I'm going to talk to stop talking about
fucking basketball cause that's about as
deep as I go. Uh, let me read a couple of,
a couple of advertisements here.
All set back.
Billy, you know, thought I
came out of the fucking clouds,
right? Okay. Dollar Shave Club.
Everybody. Oh Jesus. Here we go.
Dollar Shave Club gives you a close,
smooth shave and you can't beat
the convenience or the price.
What is convey all convenient
cause they bring a teeth.
There's nothing convenient about shaving.
It fucking sucks.
And when you were a kid, all you want to
do, you'd be get old and fucking shave.
It's the fucking worst. It's so
ridiculous. Mad that you didn't,
you didn't have to shave for
like the first fucking, I dunno,
1314 or 10 if you're one of those
fucking hairy people years of your life,
you want at least a goddamn decade,
12 years without having to fucking shave.
Although you never know today with the
other horse tranquilizers that they put
in their fucking food. You've seen
kids today, you know what I mean?
There'll be like some fourth grade boy
with a beard talking to some fucking
fourth grade girls who's beginning
to have titties. You know,
we'll be there like nine or 10 years
old. You just sucked at it. But that,
those fucking, and those little
people now they've just bring,
just been drinking the milk from the
cows that have been fed or the cows.
And that's the result. Then make
it a little fucking adults. Um,
you don't have to choose between settling
for a cheap bag of disposables are
paying out those out the nose for raises
with a laser pointer and 17 blades
awful than dollar shave club broke
onto the scene with a smarter choice.
Before Dollar Shave Club,
there was no middle ground.
It was either saved money and get a
painful shape from a disposables. Uh,
like the ones that give
away for free at the gym,
which felt like shaving
with a piece of glass.
I will tell you going from one blade,
the two blade was great. Everything else,
three, four, five is all been
fucking complete bullshit. Um,
two blades is the perfect one.
That's the one you want.
The third blade one became too thick
and you can't get under your cute little
button nose to shade there.
So you've got to start fucking
grabbing and pushing it up.
Giving yourself a pug nose like that
completes fucking Psycho Orange County
wife. When are they going to
retire? Those fucking broad my,
every day there's like a,
they're like unseasoned 98.
I walked by the TV and I'm like,
that fucking lady still here.
She hasn't gone to the loony bin.
Her fucking nose looks like the,
it's like the Lincoln and the fucking,
uh, what's that other tunnel in New York?
Have I, did I move away that
long? It wasn't the Hawthorne,
the Holland.
Brooke.
What's the one down there by a fucking
Deniros restaurant to the Holland tunnel.
Jesus.
I guess that joke's over.
It's going to say her fucking nose looks
like the Lincoln and Holland tunnel,
but you know when you can't remember
the other name of the tunnel bill,
can you just complete the raid?
Okay.
Dollar Shave Club is the best of
both worlds. You get premium shave,
the dish premium shape quality
at the disposable shave price.
If you haven't tried dollar shave
club yet, you're missing out.
It's an amazing shave
at an affordable price.
There's no smarter choice in the market
and right now they're giving away a one
month trial of any of their razors
for only a dollar with free shipping.
And that's an after that. It's just a
few bucks a month. Jesus fucking Christ.
Can you just give them the website?
There's no long term commitments,
no hidden fees, and he can cancel
whenever you want. Get your $1,
your $1 trial@dollarshaveclub.com slash
bar that's dollar shave club.com/.
Bar I really don't feel like
fucking read these this week.
How many of these, ah,
for fuck fucking sakes.
I can never be president.
Okay.
I could never sit there and read the whole
speech. I couldn't do it. I'd be like,
guys, can we, can you
cut this down? You know?
Yeah.
Ask not.
What's your country can do by
you fucking figure out the rest.
All right Hallux.
He looks,
yeah,
you're unique. You know,
walk like everyone else.
Talk like everyone else or
sleep like everyone else.
So why is your mattress one size fits all?
Because it truly customized mattress
will cost you five to 10,000 bucks until
now. Is that true? Go to hell,
x.com answer a few simple
questions and they'll run it.
Three D biomechanical model of your body.
Creepy
people, fucking robots, robots,
fogging p Bulb,
a model model model of your body through
the proprietorial algorithms they
develop with the help
of the world's leading,
leading arrogant and allies
and Baila Kanick experts. Well,
there's a bunch of big words. There must
be a comfortable mattress. The result,
the most comfortable mattress
you've ever slept on. There you go.
He licks customers report a 30%
improvement in overall sleep quality.
Well, how the fuck would you know
you're asleep? Yeah, but my dreams,
there's so much nicer. And for
couples, okay, now they get, oh Jesus,
he porno music. Now they customize
each side of the mattress.
Is there a side of the mattress and
muffles your apartment is snoring.
Your mattress arrives at your door
in about a week and shipping is 100%.
That's why everyone from Gq magazine
to Forbes are all talking about,
uh, he likes sleep. You have 100 nights
to try it out. And if you don't love it,
they'll pick it up for
free grouse and give it,
give you a 100% refund, no questions
asked. Oh my God. That's disgusting.
Go to helix, sleep.com/burn and get
$50 off your order. That's helix.
sleep.com/burr.
He leaks sleep.com/berm ah,
here we go. But Oh, boat
Boomi, Andy's me, undies,
jazz and on a fucking mattress, dude.
Dude, dude, me undies, me undies.
Three weeks later you can give it back
truss to those fucking creepy con.
Stay show up with Hazmat suits and
a couple of been fucking cakes.
I don't know what I'm singing about.
Bunch of balls will feel nice
and velvety on your new mattress.
Maybe you shave your balls with dollar
shave club or I picture a world where
putting on a new pair of
underwear isn't just fresh.
You're stepping into a better day.
Think about it under,
where's the first thing you put
on in the last thing you take off?
Why would you settle for anything less
than the best feeling underwear on the
planet? Um, maybe because
you're satisfied. I don't know.
Maybe cause you don't think about it.
Please include all of the
following points during your read.
Me undies focuses solely on producing the
most comfortable underwear you've ever
experienced.
Flatter me or Putnam wears him.
He wears him when he hacks into the
Democratic national fucking convention.
And you know what,
if Hillary had been wearing them,
maybe she would have won the election.
You know,
I was watching a little bit of the
Golden Globes last night and Jimmy Fallon
made a joke about the popular vote
versus the electoral vote. You know,
it's so funny watching all these liberals
having a problem with that fucking
like,
why do you have a problem with it?
Because you think it's fucked up or
because your person lost. I can't,
I can't fucking like literally
watching that politics shit. It's like,
it's like watching Yankees,
red sox,
my friends at [inaudible] sent me a
few pairs a while back and now I can't
imagine wearing anything else. Well,
I can't imagine where I can, you know,
I have a hell of an imagination.
It really makes each day that much
better for the price of two cocktails me
undies, we'll deliver your new favorite
pair of underwear right to your doorstep.
Better Day guaranteed. Try them on and
if they aren't the most comfortable,
best feeling uneasy you've ever had,
they'll refund you and let you
keep your first pair for free.
Included in the price is the
sweet touch of modal, modal,
especial fabric made with the best in
class materials that are scientifically
proven, scientifically proven to
be three times softer than cotton.
And you can believe that cause
modal paid for those fucking
research scientific experiments. I
don't fucking know. These Uber Cozy
undies are sold exclusively on the me
on these website where you'll enjoy free
shipping in the U S and
Canada and for a limited time,
everyone in my audience gets
20% off their first order,
but you have to go to our special URL,
[inaudible] dot com slash per with the me.
Andy's better day guarantee. You have
nothing to lose, so don't wait any longer.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash per
right now for 20% off your first order.
That's [inaudible] dot com slash bar hey,
you know what?
Somebody came up to me the other day,
Bill due to to do it, and they go, hey,
did you see that story about the pit bull?
These peep,
this family tried to put a Christmas
sweater on the pitbull and it fucking just
snapped and mauled this woman and
you know what I said? I said, hey,
did you hear about the Cocker Spaniel?
That bit, that little girl's ear off?
And then the person goes, no, I didn't.
And I said, of course she didn't.
It is. They don't report on
it all the other shit first.
So I look up this whole pit bull thing
is once it all people just going like
these pitbulls man, too crazy.
They're licking your face and,
and they love their owner. And then one
day they just killed them in their sleep.
All this bullshit. I looked
it up. Okay. Two things. One,
the dog's name was Scarface.
Repeat the dog's name was Scarface.
Number two, they lived in Florida. Okay,
can we quit blaming
the fucking breed here?
Jesus fucking Christ.
They're poor fucking dog.
I can't imagine the abuse that that dog
went through. The dogs named Scarface.
What kind of dog do you
think they wanted it to be?
What do you think they trained it to be?
That's what the fuck they did.
Do you know when I was a kid, we had
a west Highland white terrier. Okay.
And me and my brothers teas,
the fucking shit out of that dog.
And it bit us routinely bit me in the
face one time. And I almost lost my eye.
You know why? Because we were
horrible to the dog. That's why.
Okay.
If you get a pit bull and you name it
fucking scar face and you start feeding it
fucking raw meat and making
it a shit eventually,
you know when you,
I guarantee you they abused the
fucking shit out of that thing.
And what happened is when
you put a sweater on a dog,
at some point its head is underneath
the fucking material and it probably
flipped out. And then what
happens is you've abused the dog.
And rather than it being a little west
Highland terrier that you can push off of
your fucking face.
You've done it to a dog that is in a way
class that you cannot fucking handle.
But then what happens is,
is they blame the dog because human
beings are so fucking precious and fucking
make no goddamn mistakes.
It's fucking ridiculous that they
keep blaming those fucking dogs.
And I know what you guys
would think of what bill,
didn't you just give away
your pimple? Yes, I did.
Because I understood that I didn't have
the capabilities as a fucking owner
because of the abuse that happened
to my dog. You know, my dog,
when I first got it,
I picked up a hockey stick to fucking
stick handle and my living room and it ran
to the other side of the room and
started shaking uncontrollably. Okay?
I don't know what the
other people did that,
but you know when you do that to
a fucking dog, you know, I dunno,
I still love pitbulls and I hate that
people come up to me with those fucking
stories. I don't give a fuck. You know,
dogs bite people all the fucking time.
All these different breeds bite
people all the fucking time.
Every day a dog bites somebody.
You're bringing a fucking animal
into the fucking house. Okay?
And if you're not a good owner and you
don't know what the fuck you're doing,
you could get bit, you get
a hamster, you're going to
get bit, you get a pet snake,
you're going to get bit. You're bringing
a fucking animal into the house.
My whole fucking life pit
bulls were biting people,
but it didn't get brought
up until somewhere in the
nineties when I was growing
up. It was one German Shepard, one
Doberman Pinscher after a fucking nother,
you know,
meanwhile,
Dalmatians are out of their fucking
mind because they're pure bred yet I,
you know, I don't know. All right, let's,
let's get back to the fucking podcast.
I just, I don't, I don't
buy into it the same way.
I don't buy into the fact that there's
people in other countries, you know,
just sitting there and more evil than
what the fuck is down the street from me.
We're all fucking human beings. Some
of us are good. Most of us are cunts.
You know, I don't even, what the fuck I'm
talking about at this point. All right,
let's continue on. Let's continue
on with the podcast here. Um,
as you might've guessed at this point,
still no baby.
So we're still fucking waiting. We are
still waiting on pins and needles and,
uh, I am getting to the fucking
point where it's just like, it's,
it's like enough already.
This is just like,
it's like waiting to go on
stage in front of a rowdy crowd.
He's just want to be like,
can you just bring me up already so
I can fucking get this over with?
Um,
oh my God.
And I'm because I become an expert at
talking people out of the vortex of them
giving me, giving me advice
about what to do on the day,
um, because they just start telling me
their stories and that'll just be like,
hey, did you see that fucking
nor'easter they just had Becky,
you've got family back east. And I just,
I waltzed them out of the conversation,
uh, because I've tried being blunt with
people being like, listen, listen, listen.
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
I don't care. I don't want
to hear your fucking story.
Your fucking story is
not going to help me.
Your story is all about you and you just
talking about yourself in everything
that you learned. I don't give a shit.
I've talked to a thousand fucking people,
it seems like in every one of you tells
me a different story and a different
thing for me to expect,
which makes me feel like every fucking
thing's a little bit different.
So for the love of God,
can you please shut the fuck up?
Can you please stop with
the verbal home videos? Uh,
I can't wait to be a dad and,
and not tell other people how to be a dad.
That is my goal as a parent.
I probably won't do it.
I'll probably fucking follow the herd
right over the cliff. It'd be like,
you know what? You got it though. Tell you
right now. Look out for this. You know?
Yeah.
Do you know? This person told
me the other day that fucking,
I would never play drums again.
The second my kids sport.
Can you fucking believe how
ridiculous setters? Yeah.
You won't be playing drums anymore.
Oh really? Well, you know, fucking uh,
Dave Grohl plays drums.
He plays guitar too and he sings
in a band while touring the world.
As far as what I've read, he's got a
couple of kids. I think he's doing fine.
John Bonham had a kid when he was fucking
19 his band didn't even make it yet.
He had a fucking kid
before his band made it.
He was a teen dad before MTV and he went
on to become arguably the greatest rock
and roll drummer of all fucking time.
You know,
one I think old freckles could
sneak in a couple of paradiddles.
What do you think?
You don't really think about parents.
I think that there's certain people that
know how to be a parent and not lose
themselves in it and actually still have
a balance in their life where they have
a card game every once in a while.
Obviously your life is, it has to adjust,
but these fucking people that just like,
they just,
they have no life and they just sit
there staring at their children.
You know honey, honey, honey,
don't tech. No, no, no, no, no, no.
They never let their kids fall down.
They don't let him fucking do everything.
They just sit there
like a fucking penguin with that
Goddamn egg underneath them.
Except the kids already born.
I don't think, I don't know.
I don't want to do that. I don't want
that to be my life. You know what I mean?
I think if a kid is inside,
considering that we were cavemen and
we used to have babies and they were in
caves in at any point,
a saber to tiger can come in and fucking
just take the kid from you and then
that's it.
The fact that you're fucking inside
with put fucking central air heating and
food.
You don't have to hunt.
You can go right down the street
and go to the grocery store.
I know I'm over simplifying this,
but I ha I have to be honest with you.
When I talked to other parents,
all they do is just give me anxiety.
I'm so excited for this thing to happen.
And then I talked to people that
have kids in and they, they,
they just dump all this anxiety on you.
And I swear to God,
I might be reading into this,
but there's like a certain like 30% of
them that take like a certain perverted
joy and making you feel
not feel well about this,
that's allegedly the greatest
experience you are ever going to have.
Like they actually take this perverse joy.
Um,
and I think that those people are
actually bad parents because I think, uh,
I'm,
I'm totally guessing here.
I think that they resent their children
and what they took from them and they
still wanted to do blow and go around
and fucking have random sex with people
and their,
their state never quite get past.
They didn't quite fuck enough
broads or jump on enough dicks.
I don't know what it is,
but I found it equally with men and women.
Like 30% of them will take a perverse joy
and trying to infuse some sort of like
preemptive misery into your fucking life.
Because I can tell you this right now,
I'm still gonna play fucking drums.
I have to, because if I don't, I
will go out of my fucking mind.
I'm not saying I'm going
to play as much as I play,
but to sit there and if you fucking think
that I'm going to sit here with the 71
green sparkle fucking Ludwig Drum pad
and I'm not going to keep fucking play in
this thing. Uh, you know those people
out there who play an instrument. Okay,
but you don't make a living off of it
and you stopped playing it because you
have a kid. Do you ever
think about maybe, you know,
just playing the instrument in front of
your kid and maybe that they'll take to
it or maybe they'll play an instrument
that they could play in the Ted together.
You could have your own little
fucking, you know, good time together,
bonding through.
Okay.
The, I dunno, the wonder of having music
as a fucking hobby. Who you hurting?
They right now, you better play that
Ukulele. Cause once they kid comes,
you're never going to play the meet.
What is this kid like?
Some little Donald Trump and he's going
to fire me as a dad if I continue to do
my little rudimentary on my practice pad.
Um,
how bout I watch less TV and the amount
of time I spent watching all the Bruins
and Celtics.
Why don't I take that out of my life and
then put that towards watching the kid
and then continue to play drums? I mean
there's this adjustment you can make,
right? Um, oh fuck. I got to
tell you this story. I um,
I always look at houses, you know,
I'm not going to sell my house.
I love this fucking place
as much as I pitch it.
That's why I bitch about it because
I love this fucking house and um,
and I'm going to continue
to fucking repair it.
Then I want to do the
fucking homeowner three 60.
And when I have the whole thing fixed,
I'm going to start over again.
And the first job, cause then now
it's going to be fucked up. Uh,
whenever I repaired at that point, we'll
then be fucked up. So anyways, I um,
there was his house for sale
and uh, I went to go see,
I went to go see it and it basically had
everything that you do could ever want.
Right. It's a beautiful house,
you know, from the outside.
It was a beautiful house.
It had a fucking pool, add garage detached
from the house with a room above it,
which to me is like, oh, there you go.
I got the kid, I got the house with the,
I got the garage with the fucking
room above it. I put my drums up.
They're turning into a drum room
slash podcast room. There you go.
That is my fucking dream. So I go over
to go look at this fucking place, right?
Knowing full well,
I'm not going to fucking buy it
because I can tell at this point.
Having bought a fucking house that
needed all the work it does as,
as I'm driving up to it,
I can already see the fucking windows
need to be replaced and it needs a new
roof.
Even though they told me,
we know we checked out the roof
day and we had some inspectors.
They said it's fine. Oh
yeah. Is that what they said?
Why are all these water stains all
over this side of the fucking house?
What's that about? I like how
the windows don't fucking quite,
they're not flush.
Look at that.
Look at the rot around all
of those fucking windows.
This House I can tell you right now is
already a borderline tear down and I
haven't even gotten into it yet. So I walk
into this fucking house and Holy Shit.
Holy fucking Shit, dude. I
took a tour of this house.
There was three separate times that I
thought I was going to get murdered.
All right.
Okay.
First of all,
we go to look at the room above the
garage first and there's just this,
this moss growing on
the side of the house,
which I don't know if it was mold or
if it was moss, it was fucking green.
And,
um,
okay.
The guy trying to sell it is, you know,
he's doing his best gun. You know,
it's a mother in laws suite. He can
fucking do this. You could do that.
There's rum to add a little more under
the garage. And I just point to the,
I'm like, what is that? And
he goes, yeah, he and I need,
need to definitely needs a little bit
of work. And, uh, so I go into the house
and this random guy live in
there who isn't the owner,
Reza a polo pony tail. It's sparsely
furnished, was made the 1920.
So it's already like creepy.
You can already feel how many people
have lived there and are now dead. And,
uh,
we just walk around the house.
It got remodeled sometime in the 90s.
He had it still had the fucking, uh,
you know,
Lon Chaney Jr vibe of it from the 20s.
And, uh, I go downstairs,
it was like a basement,
which they just don't have out
here. And, uh, the guys like,
he can make this into a TV.
Roman,
there was all like these fucking files
and film and all this shit down there.
And like,
you know,
that was the first time I was thinking
about like a saw or the Blair witch.
And I'm like, all right, uh, can we go
back upstairs? So we go back upstairs,
we go all the way upstairs and there
was this random like teenage girl living
there that was the daughter of the
dude downstairs who wasn't fucking,
who lives there, but I don't
know, it's not as house.
And we look up there and
this is stuffy fucking smell.
And then as we go down to go to the master
bedroom, they said, oh, the owner is,
uh, the owners, just to let you know,
the owner is there. He's in the house,
which usually they fucking leave.
There's all these people just there.
And this fucking cat just sitting there
looking at me and I do the after you to
go to the master bedroom and
he does the after you to me.
And then I did want to be rude.
So now I'm walking towards the master
bedroom down this creepy fucking
Transylvania Hall with
the, the, with the fucking,
the guy, Smiley real estate agent
behind me who, you know, he's still,
I'm sitting there going like,
he's regular looking good looking guy.
That was to make me feel safe and now
I'm fucked and I'm walking towards this
fucking door.
Okay.
And I opened the fucking door
and I look in there and I swear to God,
this is guy with like gray skin,
totally fucking bald, like the landing
strip. And then like, you know,
like the little fucking,
uh,
Mr whipple fucking hair around the side
that he's Sorta died at some point,
but now it was like this gray,
he was totally gray.
You could see the veins in the side
of his head, like Clint Eastwood,
but not like, I wouldn't
want to fight Clint Eastwood
more like, did this guy die?
And then come back and he was
sitting down, hunched down,
I think he was typing
on the side of his bed.
The place was a mess and he just
sort of looked over me and say, hey,
he looked like the fucking dad and uh,
the Texas chainsaw massacre.
And I was just like,
what the fuck? So I only
like, hey man, how are you?
I sort of stepped around him and then
when I went to look into the bathroom,
which I did for fucking two seconds,
you know,
trying to feel the backside
pressure by the way, you know,
they're going to quarterback doesn't
feel the rush of trying to fill that
fucking axe.
It was about ready to go into my back.
I look into the bathroom
and all along the bathtub,
this guy had knee high
dress socks drying on the,
and I was just like, and
I was just like, hi man,
I'll fucking see you later.
And I did.
I like give us see that
walk racing that they,
that was a big fad in the 70s I did
that right out of that fucking house.
And I told, I said it real
state guy. I go, Jesus Christ,
I can see why this has been on
the market for so fucking long.
How the fuck he supposed to sell it
when the goddamn creep kipper keepers is
creek keeper, the crypt keeper.
I'm like verbally dyslexic.
Forget about trying to read.
Um, is sitting up there.
I didn't dare look,
you know I was standing there and I said
all this shit and all those old houses,
you can hear everything
when you're outside.
I was standing right underneath the
fucking bedroom window and I didn't dare
look up there cause I had a feeling he
was going to be standing in the window
staring at me and I was going to have
fucking nightmares and a, and I just,
I just,
I fucking left.
I left and I have this creepy fucking
feeling that because I went into that
house, I got exposed to something and
at some point today, my home phone,
which I never use,
so it never fucking rings is going to
ring and I'm going to pick it up and it's
going to be that guy's
voice go and day age.
And then I got to somehow expose somebody
I know to it so I don't fucking die.
Having said that, it was a great
house that had a lot of potential.
Oh my God.
Okay.
Jesus Christ at that house needed a giant
fucking hug needed to get that guy out
of it and just the,
you needed to buy all the sage in the
state of California and fucking set it on
fire. And if one thing, he either happens,
either burns out all the spirits or it
burns down the house and you start over
again. Um, having said that though,
despite how fucking creepy it was, uh,
the fact that it had a room over a garage,
that's,
that's the only way I would ever leave
this house as if I could find a fucking
house. You know? I Dunno.
I got to get out of this fucking state.
I got to get out of this fucking city.
It's so fucking stupid. Every fucking
house. I don't care how nice it is.
You can literally stick your hand out the
window and before your hand completely
extends,
you can touch your neighbor's house.
Yeah.
It's unbelievable. It's like
where the fuck do you have to go?
There's just too many fucking people.
Um, anyways, plowing ahead here.
Um,
yeah.
Should I do some breeds for this week?
Let's do some rates.
Why don't we get here? I got a little
more advertising to go. Uh, who,
who the fuck wants to listen to me
read out loud anymore? Let's, ah,
let's read some of the, uh, some
of the questions for the week.
I read two of these and then the last
two advertising's. How about that?
All right. And then I'll read the
rest of the questions. All right.
Polish invention. Hey
Bill, I saw this on reddit.
Kind of fucked up. People
go to read it, by the way.
How do you even figure out what's
going on? It looks like computer code.
People always tell me
you got to go on Reddit.
It's like I put it looks like the
fucking declaration of independence.
I'm not reading all that shit.
I saw the on reddit.
It was a machine made by
some Polish guy to cut wood.
Does knowing it's Polish make
you double guests yourself?
Double guess yourself as to whether or
not it's good invention because of Polish
jokes. Double guests yourself in this
guys making fun of Polish people.
I definitely did. I'm at the point
where I have no idea your thoughts.
Um, well I don't know how to clean. I
got to go back here to click the link.
I can tell you this.
We don't,
I don't think we need any better
way to cut down fucking trees.
Do you ever see that fucking invention,
right?
It looks like a fucking bulldozer without,
without the bulldozer front end.
And the thing just reaches out, grabs
the tree, rips it out of the ground,
turns it fucking horizontal and it goes
right up one side down the other and
completely strips it down.
And it does this within like fucking
okay.
I Dunno it within 10 seconds.
And literally one man in that machine
could do the work of like an army of
lumber jacks for a year.
It's a,
it's terrifying when I sought
to be honest with you. You know,
as I talk about looking at a house
that I don't need and then redoing it,
what are you going to Redo it,
bill?
What are you gonna Redo it
with the fucking would that,
that machine cut down? Um,
all right. Let me see
if I could find the, uh,
all right, here's the link. Let
me look at this thing. All right.
Oh Gosh.
Well,
you know what?
I know you're making fun of Polish people.
This is just some guy in his
backyard came up with this.
I bet you couldn't come up with this
fucking thing. And to be honest with you,
I just had to cut up my Christmas
tree for this year. Sorry.
I'm sure that was really annoying
to listen to. Uh, that's great.
Let's see what people say underneath.
This is way better than the a
thousand degree knife videos.
I'm irrationally angry at the completely
different sizes of cuts of the second
log short out of fire load.
We specialize in short firewood.
I don't even know what this guy
put on there, but he basically,
he hooked it up to his,
uh,
what's that thing between the
transmission and the differential? Uh,
passed a universal joint.
I'm going fucking blank here.
He basically just hooked it up to that
and he's using the engine turning of the
engine. Um, why, why,
why do people just hate on
everybody out there? Good for him.
I don't know. Fucking why does I
suppose to trash Polish people?
I like Polish people.
I liked their food and uh,
I dunno. I mean, I'm, I'm sure
they've made movies about it,
but not here in the United States because
we're so focused on our own fucking
point of view.
Like most countries,
but Poland I'm fascinated with
because during World War II,
they were sandwiched between two
of the biggest mad men of all time,
Adolf Hitler,
Joseph Stalin.
They were stuck in
between the two of them,
the most precarious fucking position
of any country that I can ever fucking
think of and they somehow
fucking survived. So I don't
think they're dumb. Um,
and I look forward Sunday to going
there and seeing that beautiful country,
eating their food and doing the fucking
shelf, having a couple of fucking beers.
All right. From Turkey, I'm sick
of being called a delusional
Spirasi see theorist by
my family and my leg.
He said,
I live in the Republic of Turkey.
Maybe you've heard that there was a
coup here last year. Yes, I did. Uh,
I put it in quotation because it was
the most pathetic attempt in Turkish
history.
Uh,
so it didn't go down like
the Ukraine. Um, long short,
your guys were losing control of our guys
who may installed here to have a nice
little proxy to the loves to the lovely
oil desert downtown deserts downtown.
I already loved how this
person is thinking. Uh,
so they try to pull the carpet from
under our guys cause God knows they can't
pass aggression wars in
your congress anymore.
Since you American citizens
are woke as fuck now,
thankfully I guess we're not cause
I don't know what any of this means.
By the way,
you don't write like you're from Turkey.
Like this is your second language.
You're using like really high level
slang for someone who lives on the other
side of the world. Um, anyways,
this pathetic coup attempt to created
a lot of turmoil here. I mean,
it would be less destructive
if it succeeded because
now through their paranoia
they are going full apeshit,
which turns Turkey to a bittersweet heaven
for conspiracy theorists like myself
with all this stuff going
on. Um, all right, well I'm,
there's no fucking way I'm reading your
name so you don't end up in a jail if
you actually are from Turkey.
Um,
I can deal with my family's indifference
to all this and my friends are most
likely are most like me
regarding these subjects.
But the fact that my girls
stonewalls me goes, mm, yeah, doll.
Okay. Really annoys me down
deep. Of course it does.
Anytime you're passionate about an
opinion and somebody just goes, oh really?
Okay sweetheart, forget about it. If
it's a woman that you have feelings for,
um, she is a totally dope
chicken. Every other aspect, dude,
you not from Turkey, you're not from
Turkey. But I'll, I'll continue with this.
Fun to hang out,
hates the movies and music I hate has c
Cup fund pillows that were sculpted by
God himself from my palms.
But I can't help lose respect for her
when it comes to her not giving a single
shit about politics and stuff.
She's convinced she doesn't get effected
by them for some reason and it doesn't
matter. I'm curious how you
dealt with this feeling. Also,
I'm very interested in how you reach
information about the world and what news
outlets you trust, uh, from Turkey with
love to you in the, uh, all right, well,
let's say you're from Turkey. Very
impressive. Your English and your slang.
You're actually better at my
language than I am. Um, all right.
Here's what you have to understand as
a conspiracy theorists is that you're,
you're really,
uh,
you're a lot to deal with and
you really wear people out.
This is what I learned when
I went down the rabbit hole,
which I got out of a good two,
three years ago,
is that as much as you don't trust
what the fuck people are telling you,
which is really common sense.
And I'm not saying there's a bunch of
fucking crazy people live in under a
mountain pulling the strengths.
But what I'm saying is that everybody is
spinning the shit because everybody has
their own agenda. So you can't,
you don't, like if you just,
if you fucking showed up to
a two car accident, okay,
both people are going to spin it in a way,
even if one person was 100% right,
there's still going to spin it.
So there's no fucking way that,
you know,
they can be perceived dig it has
spinach just because the other person is
spinning just to offset
their spending of it.
It's like listening to that whole
fucking Russia tapped into a, you know,
hacked into our shit. You're going to
listen to the Democrats spinning it,
the Republican spinning at the CIA,
spinning it and then fucking Russia
their spin on it. So at the end of it,
who the fuck knows what happened?
I just love how it,
our country is acting like we don't spy
on Russia and we don't try to influence
elections around the fucking world and
we haven't placed people in power taking
people out and all of that.
It's fucking hilarious.
All of a sudden it happens to us and
it's a big goddamn tragedy. So, um,
I would say
respect the fact that
she's not into politics.
I'm envious of people that can then, you
know, I kind of did that after a while.
Like after awhile it's just like
you're screaming into a tornado.
All right?
It's way bigger than you are.
MMM.
There are people out there that have the
ability and the influence to fucking,
I guess turn shit around.
But I'm not that guy.
I'm just some fucking guy
ruining your beer at a bar
by bringing all my delusional
paranoid fucking thoughts,
whether I'm right or not,
which I was probably right on a few
things like Mel Gibson in that movie where
he drove the taxi cab. I was probably
right about a few fucker. Thanks.
But I don't know what they are.
So all you're doing is just
annoying the shit out of people.
And I have to be honest with you,
if your girl actually loves you and
she's to the point of responding of yeah.
Darl okay.
I think you've probably worn her down.
I bet she didn't say
that in the beginning.
She probably listened to
it and you probably freaked
her out and you don't have
a solution.
You're just saying all this fucking
shit that's just gonna ruin her day.
So maybe that's her defense mechanism
and I'm, what I'm doing is I'm not being,
I'm not going doctor Phil here and just
siding with the woman because I don't
have a female audience. Unlike
that fucking dishonest con. Right.
You need today what Shay says.
Wow.
When you look ladies,
when you look at Doctor Phil,
when you honestly look at that man,
do you see somebody do honest?
Do you not see how volatile
the human being that guy is?
Can you just imagine living with
that man when he loses his shit?
His Shit.
Just imagine,
okay,
that semi bald head and face
just beat red screaming at you.
His spittle getting caught
in his mustache. Just imagine
that. And he's a man too.
Okay.
I'm telling you,
I know he's got that southern drawl and
you just think everybody's a fucking
gentleman. You know the way women
love of foreign fucking axe.
I guess guys like it too. I Dunno. I
don't what the fuck I'm talking about.
Anyways, let's get back to this guy. Um,
to lose respect for the fact
that somebody is not into,
what the fuck you're into is,
uh, ed, that's a sign. You know,
it'd be one thing if she just didn't
give a fuck about a ma. I don't know. I,
I'd have to know who the fuck she was.
That could just be a defense mechanism
where it's just like, whatever,
it doesn't affect my life.
You know,
I've done that with global warming
and all of that type of shit.
I've just started to block it out because
there's nothing I can do to get people
to, I don't, and I don't even know what, I
don't even, what the fucking solution is.
The only solution I have is too
fucking exterminate. Most of us,
90% of us, and they're just
fucking, everybody sits in
a ball and hopes that, uh,
everything that we've put into the
earth and into the air kind of goes away
after a while.
That's the only solution I have,
which I don't think that
that's going to work. So, um,
I dunno, I just, you know, I, I try to
fucking do whatever the fuck I could do,
which is, you know, I dunno. See, dude,
this is why people don't
like could see you, Lee,
you literally bringing this up is Brent
brought me to a dark fucking place and
your email alone just told me that
just got me to say that we need to
exterminate 90% of the people on the
fucking planet. How insane is that?
How are you going to do that, bill?
You're going to do that to babies too,
or you're not going to do babies,
but you're going to kill all those
fucking parents and then what you're gonna
have the most giant fucking
nursery like it all.
It all unravels the whole fucking thing.
That's why I kind of stopped
doing the conspiracy theory thing,
even though I still throw it out
there because it's fun. And I,
and I also don't believe a fucking
word anybody's telling me, um,
when it comes to that shit,
you know, one on one. You know,
if I sat down with somebody and there's
not cameras around that I could feel
like they can really be honest with me.
But the second year on TV, you know,
there's only so honest
you could be. Um, so
yeah,
I dunno,
I,
I would probably guess that on some
level you're a lot to be around during
certain new stories and uh,
I think you should lighten up a
little bit. Take your girlfriend out,
go get a fucking ice cream and enjoy
the fact that someone is beautiful as
you're saying is she is actually
can tolerate you and your,
your fucking theories. All right. Having
said that, if I ever go to Turkey,
I'll definitely have a beer with
you and then I'll fucking, I'll go.
I'll go fucking Tofa toe with you
Helen. Conspiracy theories. Um,
all right. And thank you for
listening to the podcast. Okay.
Girlfriend was unwillingly married.
What?
All right, dear Billy psycho tits. I don't
know what that, but I liked that one. Um,
25 years old and finally found out the
girl of my dreams and finally find the
girl of my dreams. Well, good for
you dude. You found it pretty young.
She's 23 years old,
smell super attractive and we have been
in a relationship for the last nine
months. I don't even have the urge to
go to bars and sleep with women anymore.
She has me all types of screwed up.
It's amazing. My family loves her,
especially my father who never gives
a shit about my relationships. Um,
she's from Yemen and is
Muslim and although she hit,
she doesn't really follow the religion.
She is forced.
She's forced to by her parents. That
being said, one weekend last month,
she told me her sister was
having an arranged marriage
and she was headed to the
wedding. I did not hear from her for
three days. She finally contacted.
Oh No.
She finally contacted me back after I
constantly reached out to her and she told
me we had to talk.
Oh No.
Once we met up,
she told me she was unwillingly married
off to a man from Yemen and that she had
no idea this was going to happen.
Oh my God.
Is this real?
Okay.
This is a lifetime script.
She told me that sends her parents
sign the marriage documents.
She really had no choice in a
religion, in God's eyes. She was,
she's married.
She made it clear that she was in love
with me and that she wanted to be with me.
Is is that fucking chick who punches
herself and the chest going to start
singing at this point.
Okay.
What's her name? She does the
casino gigs. She's from Canada.
She sang the titanic song.
Right.
Okay.
Leonardo Dicaprio
ship, whatever the
fucking song. No, that's,
that's in the arms of the angel.
That's about rescue dogs.
What fucking song? Oh yeah. Nina fall.
Woo.
Ugh.
How much does she fucking hate that song?
Having to sing that to a bunch of
casino dope sitting there and flip flops
getting teared up, you know?
Anyways, she made it clear with me.
She made it clear that she was in love
with me and that she wanted me to be with
me only she told me she pleaded with
her parents, but they wouldn't budge.
We then came up with the date that
if her parents still wouldn't budge,
she would just move in with me out of
her parents' home and we would figure it
out together.
During the during the week after text
messages turn to about three messages a
day and I did not get to see her at all.
Okay.
All right. Then this, you
know, even if you made this up,
this is an incredible story.
I think.
Got a message from her best friend
and she told me that her debt,
my girlfriend was lying to me. Oh, now,
now who do you believe?
She told me that my girl had been
engaged since she was 16 years old.
Her new husband is forcing himself to try
to fuck her and she is threatening her
and is threatening her with
violence. All right, dude,
this is going outside the realm of,
of my silly little podcast
here as well as taking her,
taking her f a way or phone.
Okay.
Um, she does make it clear that my
girl does love me with all our heart,
but we'll never leave due or a parent's
disowning her if she decides to leave
this marriage. What the
fuck? Oh, what period?
The period fuck period.
I immediately contact my girl and
she admits to everything she told me.
She knew about the wedding beforehand and
doesn't think she could do that to her
family. He's trying to have sex with her,
but she cries and then he just stops.
Oh boy. Well, you know what? I commend
that other guy. You know what I mean?
Any guy who can plow
through a woman crying.
That's just a fucking animal that needs
to be shot in the back of the fucking
head.
So this guy is actually not a bad guy.
I don't think he's just wrapped up in
the fucking custom. Ah, Jesus Christ.
Gotta love religion. Everybody,
I have no idea what to do.
She won't go against her parents,
but she loves me and she's just given up.
Uh,
she was such a strong and tough person.
Now she just going with the unwilling.
Maybe she should just keep prying and
that guy's decent enough to do due to just
be like, all right, you
know, fuck this over tea.
Or a friend told me she's depressed. It
doesn't have the fight in her. Currently,
she's blocked by friends,
our mutual friends.
And our family off from social media,
by family and friends
had been calming me down.
This guy who thinks he owns my girl
would get American history x curb stomp.
If I find out he lays a hand on her.
All right.
This stop being funny like
at least nine paragraphs ago.
Like I usually have like lighthearted,
funny shit here.
Okay.
But that might also complicate things
for her. Yeah. If you murdered the guy.
Absolutely. Anyways, I love your podcast.
Don't stop what you're doing and go
fuck yourself. I don't believe that.
I don't believe that story. I'm not
saying Shit like that doesn't happen,
but I don't believe that someone would
write this level of serious shit into me.
Um, yeah, I don't put that deck.
That got a little too
fucking sensational for me.
Not saying that shit like that doesn't
happen, but know if that actually is true.
I don't know why you're
writing to this podcast.
Okay.
I think at that point you need to
write to a, I'm going to say is wrong.
Is it Niamh Lisa Ma, Liam Neeson,
that fucking guy you need.
You need to write to that guy and find
out who wrote the scripts and the words
that he said,
and then find out what they base that
off of and gradually go back and find
whoever the fuck Liam Neeson,
namely some is pretending to fucking be.
I should know who that guy
is fucking name is, right.
Considering I act every once in a while.
I should know who one of the
best guys out there. Liam Neeson.
Oh,
Liam Neeson is born in 1952
Jesus Christ deck guys like 60
63 fucking years old and I
still wouldn't fuck with them.
Not even remotely. You know,
certain actors that play a
character and you're like,
hey,
he's just pretend to be a tough guy.
Then there's other people where
you're just like, you know, you know,
I think that guy could really
beat the shit out of me. You know,
you just saw on the ground,
where does this seat all right,
banged friends, virgin x, dear Straw,
Billy pubes forever a month back.
I recently acquired a recently acquired
friend was at my house and unbeknownst
to me, his girlfriend at the
time was my next door neighbor.
Okay.
All right. I was just thinking about
the Beatles. I got to strike that.
Let me read this a month back
a recently.
Oh, Jesus Christ. You know
what? I forgot. I got to read.
Those are the two advertising's. I know
you guys like, what the fuck? I know.
Just just let me just knock these out
really quickly. Can I just do this here?
All right. I did me these. Oh, wait
a minute. Why don't we have one left?
Yeah.
Oh, what a bonus. I got one left.
stamps.com this is an easy one. All right.
Ah,
our old friend,
stamps.com what great resolution
you can make for the new year.
Maximize every minute and every dollar
for your small business that and stopped
drinking in front of your children.
Think about how much time you've wasted
going to the post office. Driving.
They're finding parking,
fighting. Old Ladies.
Just use what you already have. Your
computer and printer to get official us.
I think they missed a paragraph there.
Um,
official US postage for
any letter or package.
Then the mailman picks it up though.
I'm missing a paragraph here.
All the bullshit you go through
going to the post office driving,
they're finding parking a
fucking smelly old people.
Crazy people going up there and having
the wrong envelope being told that you
have to go back to the,
the end of the line thinking your next
and then fucking that the person puts the
sign up next window please. And
there's no windows open, right?
Imagine if you could do everything you
could do with the post office right at
home. What? You can do that with
stamps.com hi. He liked that at rift,
that whole thing.
Just use what you already have your
computer and printer to get official US
postage for any letter or package.
Then the mailman picks it up.
It's simple as that.
With stamps.com everything you
could do with the post office,
you can do right from your own desk and
at the fraction of the cost of one of
those expensive postage meters. I use
stamps.com whenever I send out my posters,
when I'm pouring myself out at the end
of my show to make a few more bucks.
It's so convenient right now.
Sign up for stamps.com.
Use My code bar for this special offer.
Four week trial plus $110 bonus offer,
including postage and a digital
scale. Don't wait. Go to stamps dot.
Before you do anything else,
click on the microphone to top of the
homepage and type in bar that stamps.com
enter burst stamps.com never
go to the post office again.
By the way,
there's still a few tickets left for
the Patrice O'Neal comedy benefit.
February 21st New York City Center.
Don't Miss Up.
Don't fucking Miss Sal. We
got a special guest. Um,
all right, here we go. Uh,
banged friends.
Virgin X.
All right, let's start it
again. Dear Strawberry,
Billy pubes forever started
Billy pubes forever. There we go.
A month back.
A recent recently acquired friend was
at my house and unbeknownst to me,
his girlfriend at the time
was my next door neighbor.
A few weeks later they had broken
up because she wasn't putting out.
Apparently they had dated for three
months and he couldn't take it anymore.
Here's the thing of Jesus. One thing
led to another. Next thing you know,
long story short, a week ago, I
was drunk with a different buddy.
One thing led to another, sorry. Uh,
and we decided it would be funny to
invite her and her roommates over to play
board games. I was pretty buzzed and
had all the confidence in the world.
I walked over to her house and it just
so happened she was the only one home
though Jesus. She invited me in it
since like some red shoe diaries.
This really happened.
She invited me in for some cookies.
Her sorority made one
thing led to another.
Hey, we go and we ended up
fucking, one thing led to another,
uh, the classic phrase, she
was obviously an experience,
so it was nothing to write home about.
This normally wouldn't be a problem
except she's my next door neighbor.
So naturally I have repeated the process
about a dozen times. My question is,
should I tell my friend?
Normally I wouldn't say anything,
but I think I'm falling for this girl.
He's been kind of distanced lately,
so he might have some suspicions.
Thanks. And Go fuck yourself.
Please come to San Diego and Coco,
congrats on the baby. Uh, he says,
is there anything funnier
than a young man with a Dick?
You know Jesus Christ, Dude. Have
you think he's getting suspicious?
She lives next door. You've
been over there 12 times. Yeah,
he's going to figure it out.
Um,
Bullock, you know, he broke up with her.
He was only there with her for three
months. How well did you, how well,
how much, how are you great
friends with this person?
You know, it gets messy. It gets me, I
don't know what you're asking me here.
You know,
it's a fucking great story.
Other than they used to be your friend's
girlfriend, but he fucking tapped out.
Maybe that's what you should say to him
when he calls you on it and just bend.
He should have tapped out. Man.
Should've kept mining for gold.
There's gold in them there. Hills. Um,
I dunno the fact that you've been with
this girl for 12 times and you think
you're falling for her.
I don't think you're falling for,
I think you'll love the convenience of it.
If I had to guess.
You really didn't write too
deeply about your fucking
bunch of fucking feelings for this girl.
I think you went further into the fact
that how you fucking nailed this girl in
your, your, your friend didn't. So, uh,
I dunno if you're really
not into this girl.
I would just pull the fucking plug and I
would never bring it up and I'd wait to
that guy as a couple of
Miller high life's into them.
And at that point I would stay out of
his wheel house cause he might fucking
sucker punch you. Cause you
know what happened. All right.
What did he say? Bang.
Friend's ex girlfriend.
So he didn't say he accidentally
did it. So yeah. Well you know,
you knew what you were doing and
you did it and now that's the,
that's that's the world you
created it and you're living in it.
So I don't know what to tell you
other than if you're not really falling
for this girl, I would stop fucking her
day. You Go. I don't care how
good the cookies are. All right.
Colin girlfriend at con a belt.
Hope Fatherhood is treating you well if
it's finally happened has not happened
yet.
Recently my girlfriend was being very
unreasonable and running her mouth about
something and I said she was being a cunt.
Didn't call her a cunt, rather
acting like one. I, you know what,
there is a loophole there.
There is a loophole there.
But when he dropped the c word,
it's, it's very difficult.
Like I've never called
my wife a bitch ever.
I've never done it the entire time
I've been, I never called it that once.
One time I did say that she
was acting like one. And uh,
she brought that up for like fucking
three years because she knew how important
it was to me to never call her that.
And she fucking,
we got into a fight and then she pushed
my buttons trying to get me fucking more
and more mad cause that's what they do.
And they're not doing it maliciously.
That's how they fight. Most of them
were guys go, what'd you talk to say?
Then you start fucking fist fighting.
Women usually don't get to that level.
So their fist fighting is they,
they,
they've already broken you down psych
psychologically and they just try to make
you as mad as they can. And, um,
if you're with a cool woman,
they'll,
they'll take responsibility for that
and it'll eventually forgive you.
So anyways. All right. So you said
that she was acting like one. Okay.
Since then she's had her panties in a
twist and thinks I owe her an apology.
I haven't given her one.
My thoughts are that if anyone male
or female is acting like a cunt,
I can call him a cunt.
What should thought thoughts
on women calling women a cunt?
And have you gotten into trouble
for calling a woman a cunt?
I've never done that. Uh,
to a woman and I've dated,
have I ever called a woman a cunt?
You know, it's funny. Much as I use that
word, I don't think I've ever done that.
Okay.
Um, no, I don't do the name calling thing.
This angry as I am.
If I ever done that.
Okay.
I've definitely like, yeah, fuck you. You
fucking psycho. I've done that. But I,
I don't, I don't do the, uh,
I don't do the fucking, the,
uh, those classics. I don't, I don't,
I don't break out the classics.
I don't say bitch cunt. I
don't say any of that. Um,
okay.
Yeah, I don't, I just don't, I saw,
I saw that early on in my
life that that doesn't work.
And I saw what it does to a relationship.
I just saw it. Um, you know,
I had a paper route when
I was a kid, so, you know,
you get to step into a lot of people's
homes and watch a little movie trailer
and a lot of times you're walking up
to the house and you can hear the, the,
the director's cut of what's going on
before you went in there, you know.
So I saw a lot of that, you
know, being from Massachusetts,
it was a lot of hotheads
and, uh, I don't know.
Okay.
As much as a, as a dick as I am. Um,
I've never done that and I can
tell you that it gets you nowhere.
So,
um,
yeah,
and the thing,
the stubborn thing that you're doing
right now that you're not apologizing for
it is going to cause
her to dig her heels in.
And what you're doing is you're creating
this toxic fucking cess pool in your
relationship.
Okay?
Yeah.
You could have said a bunch of other
words and you went to def con five or
whatever the fuck is it. One is one
the worst. There was five, the worst,
whatever the worst one.
You went new killer honor.
I think you should apologize
and just say for the record,
I didn't say you were a cunt. I respect
you enough to not call you a cunt.
I just said you were acting like what?
Okay. I won't do that in the future.
I was wrong. Don't even don't
even defend you, but just say,
I apologize for what I said. I
shouldn't have said it. Just,
just apologize. All right. And
there'll be some residual shit,
but I can tell you, write this right
now. If you're gonna make a real, uh,
a relationship work, when you're in
the wrong, you have to apologize.
You have to do that because
if you don't apologize,
if you always get your fucking backup,
if you fight them every
fucking step of the way, then
yeah,
you stopped being a person to them. He
just, this thing you just, this loud,
annoying fucking thing. Okay?
But if you say you're sorry.
Yeah.
If he ever, if you say like,
you know what? You're right
in blah, blah, blah, blah.
The Times when you actually
are defending your position,
you have clout because you admitted
that you were wrong when you were wrong.
So there you go. Now I'm not saying
she wasn't being a cunt, okay?
Now,
okay,
that's the type of thing.
If you want to say that, that's what you
say when you got you one fucking buddy,
who for the most part can keep his
fucking mouth shut. But even then,
he can't depend on that.
Okay?
If you're ever going to call you
woman a can you fucking do it.
You go for a drive and you do it in your
car by yourself and you yell everything
that you want to yell because
she's not listening to you.
You make all your fucking points.
You're fucking crush it.
You give you a closing argument to
the invisible jury inside your car.
And then in the end,
you know,
and if they actually stopped
for a second and listen to me,
you don't understand that,
but you can't because
you're such a fucking God.
Right?
And then you look over,
you know,
at the other person is sitting
there at the red light with you.
And if it's another guy, if
it's me, I'm going to laugh.
Yeah, no, not at you, but I'm going to
laugh. No one what the fuck you're doing.
And if it's a woman,
she's probably going to laugh.
No one what the fuck you're doing.
Or if she's a cunt,
she's going to fucking squint her
eyes at her and be more of a cunt.
There you go. So, um, yeah,
I do not.
Nor would I ever do that.
I would
to the, to the, to my wife, I
would never fucking do that.
I wouldn't do that to any woman
that I was in business with.
I wouldn't do that with any fucking PR. I
wouldn't do that in general. Uh, but, uh,
generally speaking,
when I talk about people,
uh,
I kind of just call men cuts.
I think it's funny to call a man a
contact to call a woman. A con is a,
as the assistant,
funny
calling a guy at Canton is fucking
hilarious. And I stand by that.
All right?
Not saying God knows that word
exists for fucking reason,
but, uh, it's just too fucking
mean and I'm telling you, you lose,
you lose in the end because, uh, you know,
they could just make your life
miserable in every court of law,
generally speaking, out there is going to
side with them. And next thing you know,
you will never play drums again because
she's going to take them from you are
right. Not The fucking baby. Okay.
That's the podcast for this week.
Uh, God bless you. All
right, you fucking cunts.
Uh, go fuck yourselves and I
will check in on you on Thursday.